(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- I'm not just saying it when I say, like,
I really believe that.
I think you're just one of
the most prolific songwriters
of our generation and
you're so underrated.
I know you've been nominated 17 times.
I know people know. But like not enough.
I think you're so gifted.
And your voice is like quintessential,
like, why I loved country
music growing up like that.
It's perfect singer-songwriter.
Your tone. There's no one like it.
You know it's you, right
when you start singing.
It's amazing and congratulations
on six nominations at the Grammys.
(audience applauding)
- I word vomit every time I see you.
- Well, it means so much coming from you
'cause you're so great.
- Oh, whatever. You're nice.
- You really are and so to
hear you say that means a lot.
- Oh, well, the felling is
mutual. I have to ask this.
Being one of the openly gay
people in country music,
that's hard in that industry.
Like, I know even for Shane,
who's our mutual friend
that you did "Shucked" with, that was hard
for him in the beginning.
Like, you know, 'cause
he was his own artist
and it was hard to get in the door.
Now he's like one of the best songwriters.
But like, do you feel
supported in the industry?
- I do.
- That's great.
- Yes, I do and I even think of a song
like "Dear Insecurity,"
how far things have come in
that last verse when I say
"she's really sure of me."
I never even thought of
saying "he," that's how far
I feel like not only I've come,
but the world has come that nobody said,
"Oh, maybe you should say he."
- Exactly 'cause previously people
that we both know in the
country music industry
that are not openly gay, like, it's hard.
And there people would
tell them, "Don't do that.
It'll shut off a whole,
an entire fan base.
And it will kill your career, maybe."
And I think it's beautiful
that you feel comfortable
and you didn't, it wasn't
even like a thought.
You were like, well this is me.
- So, and I had all those same concerns.
You know, Shane and I
are around the same age
and came up in the same time.
But I just, I knew not
being me would kill myself.
And so, you know.
- You gotta do.
Yeah. I think it's such a
great thing too for other,
have you ever heard from other
artists that are younger than you?
- I have, in fact, I had a
moment that really touched me.
Brook Eden, she came
out and she got married
and had this beautiful wedding,
I think it was in People Magazine.
And I texted her to congratulate her about
being so authentic.
And she said to me, "You being
you has made it easier for me to be me."
And that really, it hits me now.
- The greatest compliment ever.
- Because you never think that
you're making a difference
in that way.
- You're just doing you.
- Yes, exactly. And that really,
really clearly, I'm
getting teary right now.
- I know. No, I am too.
Anytime I see someone cry,
I'm like, it's contagious.
I'm like, oh my God, I'll cry with you.
So, congratulations,
"Shucked" is incredible.
And I have literally been in the process
'cause I've heard from Shane
like the whole time too.
Like it's evolved
and it's been like a
decade in the planning.
- We've always had a
dream of you being in it.
- Oh my God. He said it first. I go,
I cannot live in New York right now.
Like when y'all first started doing it.
And now I live in New York, but yeah.
- That's always been a dream of ours.
- But, well, just so you know,
I'm such a huge fan of it.
It is so great. The music is so great.
I mean, Tony Award
nominated. That's incredible.
Did you ever think that
would happen in your career?
- No. It was a bucket list
for me to write a musical.
But it was one of those things
that I always thought
was way down the road.
And so it came around at a beautiful time
because when Shane
and I jumped in, we were
both so naive to this world.
We didn't know it was gonna take 10 years.
So, you know, you start
looking at your life
and you're like, how many
more of these do I have in me?
So I'm glad we started when we did
because we both loved it.
And man,
there were times I didn't
think it was gonna open an
Envelope at different times.
much less open on Broadway.
So it was a real, it's been a
real testament to persistence.
And he and Robert Horn who wrote the book
and myself, our friendship,
we're like family.
- Yeah, well after 10
years, it's a lot of work.
Hope you like him. It's
like hanging out a lot.
So this last album, I
think we can both relate.
My last album was very personal.
Probably my most personal, and this
is very personal for you.
And it's, I think the,
I love all your albums.
I've been such a fan,
but I do love that you've like, kind
of broke the walls on
several of these songs
and really let people in.
I feel like you've kind of
always been that artist,
but it feels like the next level.
Do you feel like that with this album?
- I do. And when I was doing it,
I didn't even realize
that's what I was doing.
You know, someone at my
label pointed out to me like,
"This is your most personal album."
And I said, "Really?" And he said, "Yeah.
I mean, a song like 'Dear Insecurity.'
Like, you're being
vulnerable about yourself,
not about a relationship
with anyone but yourself."
- Really holding yourself accountable.
- I'm really proud that you know,
that this album ended up doing that.
And then like you said,
the production, the
production's so vulnerable
that it's just, you're naked.
- Well let's do another commercial break.
Brandy's latest multi Grammy nominated
album is called "Brandy Clark."
If you don't win one of
those, I'm gonna protest.
It's out now.
I'm like nominated 17
times. Come on y'all.
She's up for six of 'em. I'm like, God.
Anyway, I'll be voting for you.